david
jordan congratulations you've made it
into the third round of this competition
good job
if you thought the last six hours was
tough it's nothing compared to the next
five days
because we're sending you back to your
home forges to recreate an iconic weapon
from history and that weapon is
the tall war i could comfortably make a
blade like this
in a week and i can uncomfortably make
one in five days
after five days you will return and
present your finished tall wars to our
panel of expert judges
only after they've put them through a
series of brutal tests will they declare
one of you the forged and fire champion
who also walks away with that check for
10 grand
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
[Music]
it's day one we're at my home forge in
kalkaska michigan
hopefully today i can get my blade rough
forged
that that's the plan anyway
i've never done a sword of this
magnitude of difficulty
so we'll see how it turns out
i just got to make it perfect because my
competitor is really good
so day one i'd like to be a little
further of course
but uh all in all it's been a good day
it's day two i'm trying to get this
blade a little longer
to fit the parameters i'm getting a
little worried this fuller is buckled
right here
when the fuller starts to buckle it
means that the wall
on either side is really thin and is
starting to move around
and there's a danger of grinding through
when you go to the grinder
so i'm gonna start this blade over
[Music]
back to working on the fuller i'm a
little behind
where i hoped i'd be
[Music]
and uh i'm exhausted
finally i'm gonna call that good
[Music]
all right day four the blade's done
now it's time for the handle i've never
made an entirely metal handle and handle
is a tricky piece of forge work so
i'm a little nervous this is uh as hard
as i
expected uh
it's cracking like crazy i'm seeing all
these cracks in my handle
and i don't have any way to fix them i'm
starting over
restarting the handle puts me about five
hours behind it's gonna be crunch time
i'm ready to be done with this handle i
was determined not to screw it up and
here i am screwing it up again
day five i had this crazy idea of doing
a damascus handle
but the damascus that i made was too
hard so we're going plan b
which is the hollow form pipe i don't
know why i didn't think of this sooner
the advantage of this was no drilling
it's pretty much ready to go and so now
we're actually gonna get the blade
polished
get the handle welded up get it epoxy to
the blade
feeling relieved and then
chop some stuff there we go
[Music]
that makes me happy nice all right
gentlemen this is the sharpness test now
the tool war was a blade respected
throughout india
so to test the sharpness of your blade
i'll be cutting into these sugar canes
dave you're up are you ready absolutely
all right
i know my weapon sharp but there's
always that little bit of doubt
[Music]
i think the sugarcane speaks for itself
there's a lot of weight in this
but it's not bad it's balanced very well
so the design of your knuckle bow uh
being inside where this this pommel is
my hand slips back there i'm kind of
whacking into that but it's
sharp nicely done thank you all right
jordan
you ready i'm ready okay let's do this
i just love sabers
this is a cutter it's fast it's light
but the
profile of your handle could be a little
bit larger from my hand
but all in all the cuts speak for
themselves it just passed through with
no resistance whatsoever
nicely done our blades they're
performing almost identical
this is going to be tight the tall war a
battle-tested weapon
but what kind of lethal damage does this
weapon do to find that out i will take
your weapon
and deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy david you're up first
you ready
oh yeah let's do this dug in the
ballistics
dummy this is the test that i wanted to
see i'm just like super excited
your edge of your blade is sharp enough
to cut and lacerate the whole torso here
cutting deep and cutting into bones same
thing with the clavicle over here and
into the ribs
your handle construction is a little bit
on the wider side but it's wieldable
overall your weapon will kill
good job thank you jordan you're next
you ready
i'm ready let's do this
all right jordan let's talk about your
blade your edge geometry here
definitely lends itself to be a very
good thruster it's sliced in
easily your edge is razor sharp
that i'm able to lacerate into the dummy
and break some bones
your handle is a little bit on the
skinny side but i'm still able to index
and hold on to it
your weapon will kill after this round
it feels like two to two dave and i
still feel really even
all right gentlemen this is the strength
test the tool war was a battle-tested
weapon
known to actually take heads in combat
to test the strength and durability of
your blades i'll be chopping four times
into these beef rib sides
this is not about what your blade does
to the beef but what these ribs
do to your blades all right dave you're
up ready
ready as i'll ever be a side of beef is
extremely tough
it can potentially break a blade or chip
a blade or bend a blades so
i'm concerned
okay dude i've got a little bit of
chipping and rolling right where the
impact is
it's not deep but it is there all in all
it felt good
all right jordan you ready guess so
i'm pretty nervous you know getting
through the bone is gonna be tricky and
all i can think is
please don't chip please don't ship
take a little shrapnel off that one
i can run my fingernail along that edge
and not feel
anything no bumps no chips still
straight
everything's still tight good job thank
you
i'm breathing a huge sigh of relief but
i know that also my handle's a little
small
and people have been sent home for
handles before
david jordan both of you have made
excellent blades and you've been
fantastic competitors but in this arena
of competition there can only be one
forged and fire champion
before i announce who that is the judges
have some feedback for both of you
dave you brought us a weapon that was a
pleasure to use it's a heavy weapon
but you balanced it out beautifully nice
job
thank you doug jordan the artistry of
your handle
is matched by the beauty strength and
sharpness
of your blade well done sir gentlemen
when weapons of this caliber come into
this arena
these decisions are never easy the
forged and fire champion
is
jordan congratulations you were the
forged and fire champion congratulations
david you created a beautiful weapon and
it was a pleasure to use it
and this decision came down to the
finest details
basically the positioning of that
knuckle bow on their handle
and those chips that turned up in your
blade in the strength test
for those two reasons we're letting you
go david please surrender your weapon
[Music]
absolutely no regrets i would have liked
it done better
but i agree with the judge's decision i
came here to prove that i could hang
with some of the best
blade smiths in the united states and i
think i proved that i can do that
jordan congratulations you were the
forged and fired champion and will be
receiving that check for ten thousand
dollars how do you feel right now
i feel great and uh i feel pretty
accomplished
well you should what a great way to jump
start my career
you're making really high quality blades
hold on this is what i've really wanted
for a long time
that's why i came here thank you i'm
fortunate fire champion
you